[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at long now this
June we hit the one year anniversary of
the interval thank you and as many of
you know we also have a nearly weekly
speaking series going on there and a
good friend of rama's is speaking next
week Hugh Howey of the wool series and
that series continues to to go on and I
think it's it's a kind of a more
intimate version of these talks and I
encourage you to come when you can or
our seating limiting is a bit more of a
factor there but eventually I hope we
can get you all in the other thing I
wanted to let you know about is that
many members have taken advantage of the
fact that we have a members discount how
many of you are members in the room all
right so you all get 10% off during the
day and all evening on Monday nights and
then we also do special events there so
if you want to hold a special event
usually up to about 30 people we can
certainly do that and then in the back
small room we can do meetings all day or
evening for up to 10 if you're really
cozy usually about 6 or 8 so anyway
please please do come by for any of
those events or for doing your own event
and for tonight's long short this is
only a 1 minute long short and since
rama's is gonna be kind of talking about
the 2.0 version of humans I thought that
a long short that gets you right up to
1.0 is what you needed enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
realities peace doesn't change as much
as we change it I notice um a story hi
I'm Stuart Brandt from the long now
foundation and it's worth occasionally
mentioning how speakers come to this
series in this case our speaker tonight
was suggested to me by shell Kevin who's
one of the earliest and longest and
deepest supporters of the long now
foundation and especially of the series
thank you and shall ran into the speaker
at foo camp and found him holding his
own with a challenging group there
suggested I take a look at the fiction
so I did and the Nexus series got me
into it so much that I was there dancing
around waiting for the third of the
trilogy to come out which it just didn't
is if you haven't read it it's outside
and I knew we had something it's
interesting when you ask ordinary
fiction writers to speak they mostly
talk about literature when you ask
science fiction writers to speak they
talk about the world and that's why I
think we get so many of them in this
series they grasp with delight and make
us grasp with delight time past time
present time future Romney is now
[Music]
well thank you very much Stuart and I
also have to thank the supporters along
now and Hugh Howey who was the
ultimately the guy who emailed me and
said hey Stuart wants to know if you
want to do a long now talk I replied in
about two seconds flat saying yes this
is a bucket-list experience for me
actually I've been a member of long now
for a long time myself so I'm going to
talk about how technology can change us
how we're choosing to use technology to
change us talking about the various ways
people fear this and why mostly I think
well we should pay attention to those
Moses's for the better and not for the
worse I am a science fiction writer I
also write nonfiction but science
fiction is really what I'm known for in
my love and as Stuart was saying this
really is the literature of ideas it's
literature about what has happened and
what might happen now in my science
fiction novels the the central
technology is called Nexus it's a drug
you swallow that gets into your brain
little nanobots attached to neurons and
transmit what your brain is doing via
Wi-Fi and can receive so it's a
technology that if two people have it
they can share what they're seeing what
they're thinking what they're feeling
even their memories and if 10 people
have it so can they and so on now this
might not be a totally novel idea to you
you might be familiar with this idea if
you're up to date on the latest and
greatest in modern American philosophy
especially the work of great American
philosophers like Keanu Reeves who
famously when knowledge was beamed into
his brain said I know kung fu
now there are really two different views
of human enhancement making us
superhuman and the one that we've heard
most about actually is the genetic past
genetically engineered babies who are
smarter or stronger and we just tall
blonde and blue-eyed and the other is
the cyborg path which is I read read
both it more the latter so I want to
dive into both of these and then a third
sort of mystery for
as well so let's start with this idea of
genetically improving ourselves in some
way Richard Dawkins was asked if he
could use one word describe biology the
word he chose was digital biology is
information that DARPA has a new lecture
series where they say biology is
technology there's a code that programs
a lot not all but a lot of who we are
and like other digital technologies the
technology of reading and writing and
misleading genes is on an exponential
path to improvement the white line here
is Moore's law you all know that this is
a log scale so this is an incredibly
rapid progress of Moore's law the Green
Line is the cost of gene sequencing and
it's going even faster there's actually
nothing we can quantify in terms of
progress that is faster than the pace of
gene sequencing and genetic science it
cost three billion dollars to sequence
the first genome and now we're on the
cusp of getting the $1,000 genome and
that means that there's huge potential
progress now to do something with that
we also wonder how many manipulate the
genome and we're getting better and
better at that how many of you here have
heard of CRISPR this and then use a bit
this is the latest and greatest gene at
any technology it's not the first and it
won't be the last but it allows
scientists to at a lower cost than ever
before and with a high degree of
precision say go find this gene sequence
and replace it with this gene sequence
basically search in a place is what it
is and it is opening up new venues and
new avenues of manipulating all sorts of
things here's an illustration I've never
actually seen a scientist of a pair of
scissors and a model of the genome but
you can kind of get an idea of what it's
like there now if we understand what
genes do and we can regulate them that
leads up to the question of could we
change them could we say take ax and
embryo that's just been fertilized
that's no more than eight or maybe 16
cells and go in there and do a little
search in our place on the genes
inside of that now this would have to be
an embryo is how we normally think of it
because by the time it's more than a
handful of cells it's nearly impossible
to reach all of them so this wouldn't be
a natural pregnancy should be an in
vitro fertilization pregnancy but then
in theory you do this you do your search
in her place and nine months later you'd
have a little baby that had different
genes than he or she was conceived with
and there's lots of reasons that people
might want to do this all right height
87% genetic all right the rest is
nutrition and so on IQ the low estimate
is that IQ is 50% heritable and the high
estimates are higher than 70%
personality traits psychologists talk
about the big five traits of personality
and these all have heritability is
ranging from 40% to 60% so these are all
things you could potentially methylate
if you want to get a sense of how wide
the scope is what we could do consider
though these numbers or consider more
broadly what we did to another species
we took wolves 20,000 years ago and
started interbreeding them we didn't add
any new genes we just selected in the
population of genes that were there and
the outcome after a thousand or so
generations maybe two thousand
generations range from dogs you can put
in your purse to Mastiffs right that is
the power of just reshuffling and
choosing among the genes that are
already in a population now there's also
the possibility of doing something more
radical right we've all seen the x-men
movies they're at the comics what if we
could take a gene that doesn't exist in
humans at all or exists very scarcely
and insert that or in some cases
scientists take a animal that has one or
two copies of a gene and insert a third
copy and that can sometimes increase the
function of this gene right there are
known examples of this here's a mutant
euro Monte ranta in the 1964 Winter
Olympics took home five gold medals his
uncle is also an Olympic gold medalist
at another endurance sport this is in
part because he has a genetic mutation
to a gene called Evo Evo tells your body
to create more red blood cells so people
who have this very very rare genetic
mutation just produce a lot more red
blood cells they have more cardio
capability right or here's another
mutation in nature there's some GMO bull
not exactly this is a Belgian Blue bull
they've existed for a couple hundred
centuries completed years sorry and they
have a mutation in a gene called
myostatin that causes them to build
about twice as much muscle mass as other
bulls and in fact we now know of five or
six such genes that can massively
increase muscle mass in all sorts of
animals and probably would in humans -
or this ordinary-looking mice is a
Doogie Mouse named after a Doogie Howser
MD if any of you remember that show I
didn't name him as the scientist who
created as Joel Chen chose that name the
Doogie Mouse has a mutation in a gene
called nr2b
and that mutation means that it learns
faster the synapses in its brain
solidified sastras neurons and grow more
connections more rapidly things that are
takes five repetitions to teach a normal
Mouse you can teach a Doogie Mouse in
one repetition and the same genes are
active in learning in the brain in the
human brain so we could potentially use
this technology to make ourselves far as
smart or at least far more able to learn
there's a whole host of more science
fictional scenarios that aren't that
hard if we pigment you see a nature
every color you see on a plant or animal
is created by a gene or set of genes
that encode some protein there's no
reason that humans couldn't have these
may be selective in certain parts of the
body why can some animals who generate
lost limbs and not humans it's due to
genetic differences they have genetic
programming that kicks into play a new
program when a massive trauma occurs in
theory humans could have that - even
aging not all species age at the same
rate trees the oldest tree alive is
about 4700 years old even animals 250
years for the tortoise
over 200 years of bowhead whale a mammal
that we share about 95 percent of our
genome with and at 150 the bowhead whale
is still going strong some of us might
like that a slowed rate of aging so all
of these are scenarios that have seemed
like science fiction until in April a
team of Siamese scientists published a
paper saying that they had taken human
embryos and actually genetically
modified them these are embryos from a
fertility clinic that could not ever
grow to a full term they had various
other problems and they did it to remove
a disease they symptom a a disease gene
nevertheless the response was a lot of
this basically we're headed for a world
of sort of stultifying conformity and
where the powers-that-be
clamped down on you if you don't have
the right genes right or if you go
further back what does gatok have a sort
of a remake of Raving your world in some
way I thought Gattaca was great actually
though wrong in the sciences I'll
discuss in a second but again brave new
world is about the use of breeding
technology to create a culture of great
conformity of great centralized control
and that's one of the big angst that
people have about genetic technologies
the other angst is about equality and
it's legitimate if the poor can't afford
this technology or the masses can't
afford this technology but the
super-rich can will that give them
further advantages to pass on will the
species even bifurcate in some way okay
so in response to this Chinese studies
as Francis Collins of the NIH he said
the NIH will not fund any studies that
involve engineering of a human embryo
even to address disease issues I
actually think this is short-sighted and
I'll tell you why there's actually a lot
of challenges to getting this technology
right one of the first ones is that
CRISPR as awesome as it is has errors
the Chinese researchers managed to make
about four embryos that had some of the
genes they wanted in them out of 50 that
they tried
they actually destroyed more than half
of those 50 accidentally in the process
and they inserted genetic errors into
the rest the technology is still quite a
ways from being ready for primetime the
other is that even though so many traits
are strongly genetic their genetic in
very very complex ways that might
surprise you
IQ more than 50% genetic but the top 69
genes involved in IQ seem to drive about
8% with the variation in the bell curve
there are probably at least 500 genes
that are involved and maybe more than
that maybe thousands personality those
big five personality traits again
thousands of genes and no one of them
makes up more than a fraction of a
percent of the variability height
you'd think height was simple alright
it's a very simple straightforward trait
but to get 8% of variation in height the
papers say you have to find 697 genes to
tweak so these are not easy especially
if every tweak imposes some chance of
doing something wrong there's also the
possibility of side effects side effects
of missing a gene because no technology
every perfect will get some things wrong
but others you won't want to you're onto
that Ipoh gene mutation people that have
that are at higher risk of heart attacks
because their blood can get so thick
with red blood cells that are becomes
difficult for their heart to pump you
see a bicyclists who dope with Ipoh
several years back a number of them died
all in one year because it all kind of
gone a little bit too far in that IQ the
single gene that has the biggest
influence on IQ in humans if you turn it
into its high IQ state you may be 1/3 of
a point perhaps you also increase your
risk of schizophrenia the doogie mice
learn really really fast they also seem
to remember a pain for much longer and
much more intensely so I'm not saying
any of these are undoable we will
probably eventually move into all of
these but if you think about the
priorities of parents in today's day and
age you think about oh my gosh is my
getting enough time in the dirt too much
time in the dirt what about the gluten
about the peanuts is a peanut free table
at school that's good parents are highly
motivated not around the newest coolest
thing for their unborn kid I love this
picture I just found this doing some
searches the Internet is awesome right I
have never heard a parents say this
except maybe when their kid was like six
or seven they were into a festival okay
but not genetically so parents mostly
want to reduce risk and there are ways
that genetic engineering could do that a
single gene change can cut your lifelong
risk of heart disease by 40 percent
right breast cancer if you have a burkha
mutation that puts you at high risk of
cancer of breast cancer or ovarian
cancer there are single gene changes
that could cut your lifetime risk by a
factor of three or four one change not
hundreds of genes Alzheimer's disease
similarly a single genetic change can
reduce the risk of Alzheimer's disease
by 30 percent or if you would have high
risk variants by much more than that so
it's actually quite hard or quite
complex to enhance but much simpler to
reduce risk of diseases and this is what
will probably fit with parental
priorities right now that's not to say
that there isn't anyone who would like
to take a risk and who'd be willing to
inject themselves with some genetic
change it's people who are interested in
exploring new states in various ways you
look and who's willing to do the most
extreme things with their body or mind
right now
it's adults in their 20s and 30s
typically and they're willing to do
things to themselves that they would
never do to an unborn child of them now
an adult has trillions of cells right
and so getting a new gene into all those
cells is actually prohibitively
difficult but in some cases we know how
to do it to a small fraction of those
cells that's gene therapy and in some
cases a small number of cells getting a
new gene has a big effect
so when animals they've been able to
take an adult animal an adult monkey and
inject a new gene that gives it boosted
athletic performance for life or a boost
of strength for life and so I think it's
far more likely that we'll see adults
use technology genetically modify
themselves where they're more willing to
take risks than they would be to modify
their unborn children and rather than
the Gattaca world of sort of crushing
conformity I think this speaks more to a
world of people using technology for
self expression or self realization none
of these people are generally modified
obviously but at least I think but
people when they're adults are willing
to use technology anything from fashion
to phones to computers not to conform a
society that we all do some of that but
also to express and explore right now
there is this issue of cost and the gap
between the rich and the poor and could
this widen that but the interesting
thing here is are the cost of
biotechnology is dropping so rapidly and
biotech is really information if you
look at any drug that's made or let's
say a vaccine which conceptually is not
that far off and it's the ultimate
complexity of making it from a gene
therapy it can take a billion dollars or
more to do the research to develop it to
think but then the cost is minuscule and
in fact the more people who want
something in medicine the cheaper it is
if you want a very high medical bill get
a disease nobody else has right if you
want a very low medical bill get
something everybody else has and then
the other costs progressively get lower
and lower alright this is information
technology so I think there's a
possibility that that nature of it means
that it will actually level the playing
field we can't be sure of that
but that's where I think the trend goes
now let me switch gears that was the
biological path of enhancement but let's
talk about the cybernetic path of
enhanced with the famous Keanu Reeves or
Sergey Brin who said several years ago
now actually we
Google to be the third half of your
brain I kind of liked the idea of 1.5
frames right now there is an awful lot
of work going into sort of the version
0.01 of Nexus if you will technology
that interfaces with your brain to send
data in or out but it's not being driven
actually by Google it's being driven
primarily by medical applications this
is a cochlear implant there won't be
here have a cochlear implant I know
someone who does
I can't see you very well so I'll assume
that was in oh I saw one hand go up this
looks like a hearing aid and it serves
the same purpose but it's not a hearing
aid this is a microphone on the outside
but some people can't hear no matter
what they have no inner ear hair cells
left so they can't pick up the sounds
cleaned up and amplify that a normal
hearing aid or pick up or would
broadcast
so this cochlear implant picks up sound
and then uses an electrode to directly
digitally input that sound into the
human nervous system it stimulates the
auditory nerve that goes then straight
into the brain this is actually quite
old technology in this in the 1970s and
people thought it was impossible because
the auditory nerve fiber has 30,000
fibers the brain the auditory cortex has
more than a billion neurons this thing
has 23 electrodes and the best versions
that we have today but it actually
restores workable hearing and it has
transformed the lives of 200,000 people
alive today like this five-year-old girl
hearing for the first time or this six
month old boy you're about to see
hearing the first sounds ever in his
life
[Music]
so Jonathan here is a cyborg he has this
wire that connects that connect to
electronics and inputs sound data
straight into his brain only into his
auditory nerve into his brain
but he's the cutest damn cyborg ever
like this is not that scary ultimately
and there's no way he could hear without
this technology so that's one form of
input how about another form of input
how about a sight this picture appeared
on the cover of Wired magazine more than
a decade ago now this is yen's nauman
Canadian gentleman he's 39 in this photo
at age 18 when he worked on a railroad
breaking rocks with his pickaxe he
accidentally hit a piece of metal and a
metal sliver came up and destroyed one
of his eyes the next year at age 19 he
was out snow mobile snow mobiling had an
accident and a piece of the clutch flew
into his other eye he didn't want to
compromise on his lifestyle so he's
blind in both eyes at age 19 okay and
that goes on for 20 years until at age
39 he is implanted with this device this
is a CCD camera on his eyeglass there
it's kind of like the version you're
can't in your cell phone but way worse
it's ten or twelve years old now if that
wire takes the data that comes in the
camera it would take it to a computer
one on his hip that was about this big
now it's the size of a quarter and then
from there that wire went up
and into this jack in the back of his
skull 256 electrodes going into primary
visual cortex v1 back of the skull back
of the brain
now there's billions multiple billions
of neurons in visual cortex area one so
you wouldn't think 256 versus billions
could actually work but it produces what
they call limited mobility vision so
that's what this looks like it was
really a nice feeling yeah so yes
doesn't have great vision isn't it the
system anymore
he didn't have great vision but it was a
quantum step up from zero it's a proof
of concept that we can take visual data
from a phone or a camera and insert it
into the brain in a way that makes sense
and in fact since then about a year and
a half ago the FDA approved the first
bionic eye it's called The Argus 2 it
goes a different way it goes into the
retina but for tens of thousands of
blind people this will actually restore
some semblance of vision you'll start to
see them around now we've also gotten
data out this is a guy named Phil
Kennedy's an urologist in Atlanta and
this patient Johnny ray had suffered a
stroke and was completely paralyzed from
the neck down he had an emergency
tracheotomy to save his life so he
couldn't talk either all he could do to
communicate was to blink once for yes
twice for now but Kennedy had done work
in animals saying that showed that he
could get data out of the motor cortex
the part that controls motion and so the
FDA gave him permission to do this in a
human for the first time and they did it
via a wireless system they did a surgery
and planted a system in his brain sealed
it back up
and then that system would speak
wirelessly to the equipment in the rest
their room and even gets power that way
and it allowed Johnny ready to go from
just blinking to controlling a cursor on
a screen and typing out messages to his
friends and family about six months in
it was a very long training but about
six months in they asked him Johnny ray
what does it feel like and he typed out
n o th ing they've been very odd to us
at first and then it became other limb
that he had more or less and this
technology is advancing too so here's a
more state-of-the-art version you're
watching the most advanced brain machine
interface in action Kathy Hutchinson is
paralyzed and unable to speak but just
by thinking she's able to control the
movements of this robotic arm and drink
her morning coffee she's part of a
pioneering study run by researchers at
Brown University in the US so Kathy
system has 48 electrodes you see it red
and width a chicken control our multi
access arm and this technology is
getting better essentially every year it
does try out that motivation is very
important to her a kid getting coffee
was after her second task that she chose
the first tasks that she chose was
feeding herself chocolate and she always
gets the chocolate in her mouth a little
messy but it always gets there alright
we've also gotten data out of the visual
system so this is a study that put
people in an MRI machine an fMRI and
showed them videos of movie clips and
then a piece of machine learning
software that had been trained on brain
scans and video clips picked out from
its own library sort of fussed out
videos which one looks the most like
what they're seeing so there on the left
is what the person is shown on monitor
and from the right is what the algorithm
using that a brain scan in real-time
picks out as it's the best sort of
approximation of what they're seeing and
it's very very far from perfect but just
by scanning the blood flow in your brain
this algorithm can figure out roughly
what sort of thing
you're looking at and that's a big
handicap not being inside the brain with
Ashe electronics in the brain there's
every reason to believe that this could
be tremendously more precise than it is
right now now all of that is sort of
sensation perception motion but we're
more than just things that move around
and see things we have we think we feel
right can we affect these higher
functions that we have who knows what
movie this is what's the name of the
actor what's the name of the character
that he plays Lenny that's awesome it
was that Molly that's my girlfriend
well thank you it is Lenny so Lenny
can't form new memories and sometimes I
wish that I couldn't die there but this
is an exaggerated version of what really
happens but things like this really do
happen and it happens primarily people
that have damaged a part of their brain
called the hippocampus a seahorse shaped
part of the brain that is vital in
encoding new memories but so scientists
been working on could they help the
millions of people around the world that
have some sort of deficit
usually did a trauma out of the head of
some sort so at USC a fellow named
Theodore Berger and his team have
developed what they call a hippocampus
chip it's a chip that gets shunted in
sort of by bypasses in the brain around
the damaged by the hippocampus and then
it processes data in the same way the
hippocampus is in fact they didn't even
really design this from the ground up
like it's fair to say they don't even
exactly know how it works
we really mimicking what hippocampus
tissue normally looks like and so I
think rats that have this brain damaged
and the rats cannot learn amazing when
the maze great they try to in a second
time it's just as if they've never seen
it before with this hippocampus chip
installed the rats regain the ability to
learn and more than that they learn
better and they get a new feature they
can I run the rats through the maze and
we record all the data that goes through
the hippocampus chip and then a year
later it's about 1/3 of a rat's life
it's called 30 years for a human they
can playback that session of data put
the rat in front of the maze again and
the rat runs it perfectly as if it had
just been there five minutes earlier we
restore memories have at least some
sorts at least four rats or these
adorable macaques have had a chip placed
in their frontal cortex it's a sort of a
learning and attention chip if you will
either a monkey IQ chip they're been
trained after the chip is implanted on a
monkey IQ tests called a pick and match
test they're shown a bunch of pictures
then they're shown a very high-speed
barrage of pictures how to pick the
right one
not the wrong ones and the question here
is can the chip improve their
performance so the chip finds out when
they get an answer right when they get
it wrong and learns what patterns of
brain activity look like for right
answers versus wrong answers okay great
then they impair the performance of some
of these monkeys on this test they do
that by giving them large doses of
cocaine so the monkeys all think they're
doing much better on the tests but in
fact they're they're doing worse in
those monkeys when the chip is in an
active mode it can actually rescue the
performance loss all the way it can
restore their performance as if they
were unimpaired
and what's more than that when they used
this technology in a monkey that's not
impaired at all it boosts their
performance on a 1 to 100 scale by about
10 points which leads obviously to the
planet of the cyborg Apes so all of that
is fantastic but the thing that but I
guess I obsess over the thing that my
novels is really about and I think is
most transformative isn't just
augmenting our ability it's the ability
to connect us computers used to be
things that used for spreadsheets or
word processors right but nowadays that
technology is used more than anything
else to facilitate our communication and
that has changed and is changing the
world and there's work going on that
shows that this is possible too
this is a study done at wake forest
university by guy named Sam Detweiler
and with Berger who did the monkey or
the rat hippocampus chip they have two
monkeys in separate soundproof rooms
the monkeys both have an implant in
their auditory cortex the part of the
brain that processes sound those
implants are connected and so they play
a sound for one monkey and the question
is can the second monkey hear it and yes
the second monkey here's the sound
happen in the other room and can
recognize what it is now the top funder
of rain computer interface work in the
world is the NIH but then
number two funder and who funded this
study is DARPA right and they came out
of a program that is focused among other
things on can they improve battlefield
communication between soldiers there was
we've seen with the internet just
because the military funds it doesn't
mean that there aren't huge civilian
applications or this study this is done
by a fella named Miguel Nicolelis they
have two rats that have both have
implants in their motor cortex that
controls their paws one rat gets trained
in an identical cages the cages have
lights that signal what lever they
should pull to get food but only one rat
gets trained to learn what the lights
mean that rat can get there at the right
level all the time the other rat has no
clue until they turn on the connection
between their implants and then the
second rat who has never been trained on
this starts pulling the right lever not
all the time they're about 70 percent of
the time right now Nicholas you can tell
he's a sci-fi fan because they didn't
write this paper up as a neural
connection between the motor cortex of
Tortola they loaded up as a meta
organism of two rats and the Internet I
like that the other thing that is
fascinating
is where these rats are because one rat
is that Nicholas's lab in Duke
University North Carolina the other add
lab is in his other lab in são Paulo
Brazil because once you make the
contents of our minds digital you can
transmit it anywhere right or at the
University of Washington about a mile
from my home this study happened it
happened today that crux my second novel
came out so to thank them for the prompt
response there they have no idea who I
am actually but it just happened to be
that way these are two professors of the
u-dub they're in separate room separate
buildings Ashley across campus of each
other the one on the left
professor Rao is playing a video game
and so is the guy on the right Andrea
Stokoe in fact they're playing video
game together but not a player versus
player and not cooperative mode they're
playing as a single player
and the way it works is Rao on the Left
can see the screen but he has no
keyboard or mouse Stokoe has the fire
button but can't see the screen
so when rao wants to shoot he thinks
about it you know he wills the fire to
happen the EEG on his skull picks up
that intent transmitted across campus
and the magnetic stimulator on andrius
Tokyo's head stimulates the part of his
brain responsible for his right finger
twitching and it twitches and he fires
he doesn't importantly he does not think
oh great gesture I wants me to shoot how
I should shoot no he just observes that
his finger went down and he shot and
burger at all who did the hippocampus
chip are it's kind of speculated
casually but what would happen had two
rats that both had hippocampal chips and
they connected them would the second rat
learn to run the maze the first rat it
would it suddenly say hey I know kung fu
I know this maze anyway probably not
there's a very very very long way to go
to that but it's still thought-provoking
but the challenges are also very real
here let me not sort of sugar-coated I
write sci-fi so in sci-fi I can say Oh
magic nanobots yada yada yada it's a
little bit harder when you're actually a
brain surgeon so challenge one anybody
know what this picture is this is Lena
or Lana this is the most famous picture
in in image recognition Ashley it's a
classic picture that's been used many
times the test algorithms Yin's the
blind guy he sees in that rightmost
version like his vision was a 16 pixel
by 16 pixel grayscale it's a quantum
leap up from zero but you would not
trade your eyes for the bionic eyes not
right now anyway probably not for a long
time to come now I'll get better and
better over time
and that we're heading into the left
side of the bottom row with new
technology but it's still a very long
ways short of human natural vision or
then there's this challenge who's
interested in elective brain surgery
yeah I'm not let me just be clear I'm
not really either all right that has its
risks in fact this is what brain
computer interfaces looked like today do
you want one of these jammed into your
skull now just two I'll be honest like I
was exaggerating a little bit so that
actually looks like but those are sharp
you still probably don't want them being
jabbed into your skull so there are many
who say look this stuff will never
really have it'll happen for the
paralyzed for the brain damage but it'll
never reach the point who will
electively choose to use this technology
but we used to also say that eyes
surgery would never become common you'd
never have someone using a scalpel to
you know change your eye you don't wear
glasses anyway but technology changed
that the excimer laser allowed us to do
something called LASIK and I went from
being ten or twenty thousand eye
surgeries a year to two million eye
surgeries a year almost all of which are
elective it's not perfect but it was
cheap enough safe enough and fast enough
that a lot of people have chosen to go
this route now is there a LASIK for
brain surgery that's a tall order but
there are things that sort of approach
that why don't we feature a fish this is
a zebrafish and if you like neuroscience
it is a great time to be a zebrafish and
the reason is with zebrafish that have
been genetically engineered using they
called optogenetics so that their
neurons light up in response to firing
and our light-sensitive with the
combination of that plus new techniques
of microscopy we've been able to do
amazing things this is a video of a
zebrafish brain firing in real time
something we've never been able to do to
any organism before now it's about two
years old and then more recently Edie
Boyd ins group at MIT amped up the
resolution and they produce videos like
this this is fast enough resolution fast
enough time resolution and good in a
spatial resolution that we are seeing
every single time a neuron fires in this
young the
fish the roof is actually in a in a
virtual reality rig it's kind of stuck
in place it's got a screen and on the
screen they show it features of bigger
predator fish and they see and they see
what happens in its frame I only get fun
videos too but you know as I was saying
if you're a zebrafish this is the Golden
Age of neuroscience but the zebras have
a couple advantages over humans one is
we can genetically engineer them so that
there are neurons light up when we get
them in certain frequencies of light the
second is until they reach adulthood
their skulls are transparent it makes
things a little bit easier so our skulls
unfortunately are kind of thick not
transparent our gray matter itself is
not transparent and most of us don't
carry out genetic genes but I know of at
any rate so we have to do other things
in humans we are making progress though
this is a proposal for Mama her bits and
so on at Berkeley something called
neural dust sounds a lot less a
technology that's essentially they would
sprinkle tiny tiny sensors throughout
the brain all across the folds and so on
and those would communicate
ultrasonically with base stations that
would then communicate ultrasonically
within a base station outside the skull
and with this they can actually go from
a few hundred neurons being sampled at a
time to thousands or tens of thousands
seven built this yet but they're getting
funding to go ahead and proceed with
this well this is the vision of a
conformal BCI those electrodes on a silk
substrate and it melts into the brain
more or less and the silk biodegrades
over time this has been built and
they're doing studies and animals right
now or just a couple months ago actually
this came out this is a neural mesh
interface is an actual picture of the
device and they've injected this into
mice is this
this interface is so fine they can roll
it up in a roll
stick that in a syringe sit the syringe
through the skull so to do something and
then inject the whole thing into the
brain and have it spread out over time
across the surface of the brain so none
of these are completely non-invasive but
they're heading in that direction right
it's it's a lot better than having your
skull kind of cut open and things jabbed
down into it well something's wrong with
my computer here sorry
actually nothing wrong with my computer
but there is this challenge as well it
says I want to animate this if you it's
not just the hardware that might be a
problem
who here is excited about a blue screen
of death inside their own skull it's me
neither okay or a malware warning or
even your antivirus thinks well you
can't download that files it's not
trusted there are issues and honestly
these issues are beyond the scope of
this talk mostly let's just for a second
though I asked what if we succeeded what
if we could get something that was sort
of like the sci-fi version where we can
make it so that anyone can in take this
technology and get millions of neurons
sort of put online what impact would
that have on the world well the sort of
obvious ones are hey we could help
people that have been physically
traumatized that can't use their limbs
anymore
we could help people with mental
maladies with depression or anxiety we
get so much more insight to being able
to look at individual neurons and
circuits what's going on inside the
brain instead of a blunt tool of a
chemical that spreads everywhere in the
brain and even more throughout the whole
rest of the body
well what about education could we speed
up the rate that people can learn things
if we could directly interface with a
brain if we could even tap into our
brain and know when they were attentive
and not attentive when they were getting
something and not getting something
people who have memory problems and so
on
really besides the augmentation which
obviously we have a huge appetite for
since people spend billions of dollars
on products to augment their thinking
that then don't work at any rate our
society wants this
to me it still comes down to this
ability to communicate that all of these
studies point at a world we will
communicate more richly faster in higher
fidelity and communicate new sorts of
things that they can't really
communicate now a new fort of swim of
media if you will now all of that I
think will raise some questions this is
not gonna be if it ever comes to
fruition something the society just
accepts without some amount of hand
wringing right and some of the questions
are really quite legit just as the
galilean revolution raised questions
about sort of who we were and our place
in the universe I think this will - and
in fact if you can use technology
whether it's genetic technology or neuro
technology to change who you are to
change what you like or your attitudes
your personality type that raises
questions of Who am I really
who do I want to be that can be a very
sort of unmooring experience
well what about individuality in a world
who we can change what people think or
just those basic personality traits
would we become less tolerant of those
who are a little different what we want
to use this technology to tweak them to
be more like us or would it go the other
way around
with people especially if they can use
this technology temporarily use it to
explore different mental states new
mental states to switch between their
everyday personality type and the first
knowledge type they're going to have
when they go off on an adventure for
instance and then there is social
justice so we get into the impact on
society as a whole maybe a mature
technology of the brain or even just
better insights into the genetics the
drive behavior will make us a more
compassionate society where we see that
someone committed a crime we kind of why
that might lighten or reduce our urge to
punitive measures right make us treat
them in a different way but there's also
sort of the converse risk this is
actually image from an advertisement
it's not a shoe store this is an
advertisement for a company that sells
criminal anklets right if we have the
ability to monitor someone or nudge
someone will we be tempted to use it
more broadly oh this person has a
predilection for violence we're just
going to give them a little tweak we
don't want to jail them what is in the
little tweaks they just don't do that
anymore
is that worse or better what if this
person hasn't committed a crime yet
pre-crime but they've got violent
tendencies we're just gonna even a
little tweak so they're not a threat to
society these are all sort of valid
concerns and they're not exactly
concerns of the technology they're
concerns of how society uses the
technology okay
now that said we we've always had this
concern about big brother information
technology has always made people worry
that we were going to use it to oppress
people to create that sort of stole
defying conformity all right
but there's other pressures it can't it
doesn't have to come from the top down
it can come from the marketplace if a
technology is available that allows you
to perform better to learn faster to be
sharper more creative but let's say it
has some side effects that aren't that
Pleasant will they be economic pressure
to adopt these technologies to stay
ahead in the rat race there probably
will be this is that today already with
all sorts of things and then the concern
that I keep coming back to that I think
is probably of all of these the most
legitimate concern and the one that I
think about most and having to stay
ahead of which is the economic concern
right who will be able to afford any
technology of human augmentation will it
be just the rich or will it be all of us
over time the biggest book of last year
the book everybody talked about last
year was thomas piketty's capital and it
really independent of the specific model
that it raised it captured the zeitgeist
was concern about the rising wealth of
the rich and they're not so rising
wealth of most of society but I want to
switch gears to another technology in
the form of augmentation both as a
lesson in itself
as an analogy because we are all already
cyborgs right we can all communicate
telepathically to people all the way
around the world we augment our memory
remember more things and we all possibly
ever could have we have become
superhuman in some way without putting
anything into our body and it's possible
that brain implant technology will never
get there it's possible genetics will
never get that good but this almost
certainly is going to keep augmenting
our capabilities just as it has today
right it has in large part because of
Moore's law because every 10 years the
cost of computing drops by a factor of
100 the power consumption of computing
jobs by a factor of 100 the amount of
storage you can have goes up by a factor
of 100 the amount of bandwidth you have
was a factor of 100 every decade every
20 years it's a factor of 10,000 every
30 years it's a factor of a million
right and that's why we all have these
incredibly powerful devices in our hands
this is the real cyborg augmentation
happening in the world
we are augmented humans already this is
who we've become
maybe this is our head to look up and
down at the same time and it's sort of
inevitable that this steps wouldn't get
better it's get more powerful so we get
more associated algorithms that act as
advisors or life coaches or just
remember your friends birthday to tell
you who it is you're looking at right
now if you don't recall their name
cheaper faster better more available to
us at all times maybe not even a
wearable so much as internally wearable
this is a prototype LED contact lens
they've got like eight pixels on it so
far but if Moore's law applies to LED
contact lenses then we'll we'll get to a
billion pixels before too long all right
so this is really happening and what is
this tell us about the rich and the poor
all right remember the digital divide
people hear that term a whole lot today
we don't hear that because it really was
the case that this was a radical
technology the only which could afford
and the sort of the way that that picked
Eddie would worry about y'all run with
Gordon GECCO right and if you know
exactly where I'm going with this
here's Gordon Gekkos cellphone that here
is the inventor of the cellphone from
Motorola and here's the stats on that
phone that the Gekko has for grant all
right it weighed more than two pounds
its charge lasts over half an hour and
it took ten hours to charge it up here
is the typical cell phone user around
the world now this is a farmer in the
state of Kerala in India I have the New
York Times how did it go from this to
this well that is that Moore's Law thing
but more than that the rich pay through
the nose for the latest greatest thing
or the early adopters pay through the
nose for the latest greatest thing they
get a fairly mediocre or worse than that
product and they fund the R&D that
drives that technology to the point that
it's far better you know this is hundred
times better a hundred times cheaper and
gets out to billions right you by the
way there's a post relator to this to
read Elon Musk's post a few years ago
about Tesla's secret plan and how they
use 150,000 dollars for its cars to fund
the development or the Model S and use
that to fund the development of a
mass-market car the same sort of basic
phenomenon right technology gets cheaper
and people who buy later on have the
late mover advantage if you will they
only make it a little bit more visceral
I went to the University of Illinois
urbana-champaign
this is ENIAC on the right the first
digital computer built at UIUC it
occupied a space about the size of this
room on the left is an iPhone 6 if you
try to build an iPhone 6
using ENIAC technology it would have a
footprint larger than San Francisco Bay
Area it would be several miles tall and
it would consume the entire power output
of California and I still couldn't play
Angry Birds or snapchat or take
and so on and it would cost somewhere
between ten and a hundred trillion
dollars to build iPhone six level
computing with and so it you say like
we're all walking here with mobile
supercomputers that's not exactly an
exaggeration that's really what's
happening from anyone from a past era
the cost of computing goes to zero the
cost of technology goes to zero the cost
of people does not but when you're
getting something if it can be mass
manufactured mass-produced it ultimately
gets cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
over time right that's why today at the
end of last year we passed half of all
adults on the planet on the Internet
right there are fewer and fewer who are
not connected in any way there are more
cell phone users in sub-saharan Africa
than in Europe and the u.s. combined in
about two years we expect half a billion
smartphone users not just cell phone
users in India compared to the 300
million people you know men women and
children in the United States Hey the
majority users of Technology are people
who we thought of as incredibly poor not
that long term are incredibly poor there
are more people with cell phones than
toilets in Africa because it's true and
sad in the same way but because cell
phones have this exponential technology
driven curve of reducing price so the
highest technology overall has been an
equalizer much more than it's been a
divider it has had some divisive
economic issues too but it's been
primarily something that has leveled the
playing field around the world and
that's what I hope that new augmentation
technologies might as well there's other
economic concerns my friend Eric Van
Alstyne and Andy McAfee have this book
it's an amazing book the second Machine
Age but the pros and cons of high tech
and AI and they particularly worry about
jobs what if a computer can do the thing
that you can do right now okay and that
their first book I think had a great
punchy title
grace against the machine but is a human
with genetically amplified ability to
learn more or less able to keep their
job is a human who can digitally connect
their brain to a computer more or less
able right we think about software and
computers as replacing humans but they
also augment humans and so it might be
that as much as racing against the
machine we're also racing with the
machine with the machines the genetic
technologies on our side and things that
a human plus a computer can do that no
computer can do on its own Naoto I'll
give another point on equality here into
the details of capital the core
assumption here that concerns vachetta
is that the return on investment R will
be greater than economic growth that
particular model of inequality is that
economic growth is going to stop we're
going to stop having new innovations or
new growth of the things that we can do
but there is reason to believe that
humans that are augmented will have more
good ideas will have more innovation
which raises that growth figure in which
case the same inequality doesn't happen
all right if you think about the
printing press right the printing press
we know a lot about it but one of the
books that I think is most seminal is
this book written by newton's principia
mathematica this is where Newton wrote
down calculus the only reason that
Newton could write this book is because
the printing press had already been
around for quite a long time before he
was born and he was able to read
hundreds of books written by other
philosophers other scientists other
mathematicians and then he was sort of
an aggregation engine that took them
added a bunch of new ideas and then
spread this book to thousands of others
right every invention in this room from
this screen to air-conditioning to your
cell phone exists because the printing
press made it easier for us to spread
ideas and
intersect ideas that increase ability to
communicate is what bootstrapped
our pace of innovation all right think
about it if you're a computer person
there's a Metcalfe's law you have a
network clearly connect people the value
goes up with the square of the number of
people you add if you have twice as many
people you've got four times as many
connections and that is what innovation
scales with we see this in cities these
in countries we see it in languages we
see it in economies so more people who
are smarter and more intimately
connected will produce more good ideas
which in turn accelerates the pace of
economic growth and then the are greater
than G potentially gets inverted we'll
see I would say I'm cautiously
optimistic I'd say that there was
reasons for all of these worries to be
on our minds and for us to look out for
them and see if they happen or not but
there's just as many reasons to hope for
great positive outcomes from here but
those positive outcomes are about more
than economics and I'm gonna close with
this the first how many people here
followed the Arab Spring closely the
Arab Spring started when police officers
in the Egyptian city of Alexandria beat
up a kid for having pot that was
videotaped by somebody with a cheap
smartphone that was put on YouTube as a
video and this event started as a
Facebook invite for an event to protest
police brutality now the Arab Spring
hasn't gone where any of us hope it
would go but that ability to connect had
a not authoritarian impact but a very
Bottoms Up
impact right the sign was posted around
then and I found it pretty insightful I
think we hope or in the US when you
think about the social movements the
outrages that we have over the things
that are happening police officers
didn't start treating black people are
worse than white people last year they
didn't start when Twitter was invented
it's been happening for a long long time
but what we have now is greater ability
to express ourselves in text and video
and sound greater ability to rally
around things that matter and that in
turn has an impact when there was a
killing in police custody in Baltimore
six police officers were relieved of
duty and one is still in jail awaiting
prosecution for first-degree murder
right now I can't read the mind of the
prosecutor but I think this happened in
large part because of our ability to
communicate because of the outrage that
grew on Twitter around this event and
around previous events like Ferguson if
you look at the City of Newark now has
the world's where the u.s. is best
civilian Commission policing the police
and again I think that's a response to
social media our newest and best way to
communicate as a collective now many
places will try to stop this if you
travel to try and that sort of a it's an
awkward situation sometimes there's what
you can and can't ask you don't even
know beforehand necessarily but as hard
as the Chinese authorities attempt to
crack down on communication they are not
entirely successful in fact they're not
even close to successful there have been
thousands of large protests in China
over the last several years usually on
one of two issues corruption or
environmental issues water quality air
quality tainted milk those are the
issues that really draw people out and
they have been successful protesters in
China have caused the cancellation of
factories and chemical facilities that
they saw as polluting their local
environment China is very far from
democracy but it's increasing the case
that China has to listen to its people
and this happens when people use their
cell phones to coordinate these protests
and in fact an acquaintance of some of
us here got her PhD studying protests in
China and she tells some funny stories
it turns out that one approaches is
going to happen
and you're going you might get a text
from someone saying oh the protest
tomorrow isn't canceled it's never been
cancelled
and everyone knows that right so
information technology even the places
that are at least free is helping make
people a little bit more free or at
least to find and express their voices
we saw a peer-to-peer encrypted chat and
Hong Kong will see more now that's not
to say that if we digitize our thoughts
will be entirely comfortable everyone
who might try to listen to that I'm not
and I think there are good grounds for
us to worry and to work on things but
despite the sort of 1984 ish vision of
the top of society using information
technology to control us instead we see
sort of the opposite instead of Big
Brother the US has been swept by
movements of compassion and tolerance
for differences and I don't think that
there's any way that marriage equality
would have happened without greater
ability for people around the u.s. to
communicate to one another
right or the legalization of marijuana I
live in Seattle so in Washington SATA in
2012 we got gay marriage and legalized
pot and I thought this is science
fiction right here right you don't you
didn't see that coming but it happened
this is one of the first information
technologies around this is Sumerian
cuneiform tablet it's several thousand
years old and this information
technology was not a liberator of the
people why because it was in the hands
of the 1% of the 1% and they used it to
run their empires which were empires
were built on the bathroom one else and
what changed was the democratization of
Technology the plunge in price and the
increase in accessibility
changed that tremendously in addition to
sparking faster innovation it allowed
people to express strange new things
the first newspapers were created
because of the printing press all right
it allowed philosophers like John Locke
to write this treatise that said maybe
we should get along with people who have
different religion
than us we look different to us which
was a radical idea at that time Lisa's
radicals black lives matter right those
ideas would never have happened if
printing was only in the hands of kings
and emperors but because everyone had it
it's spread those ideas were the
foundation of the very notion of civil
rights and civil liberties again spread
from the bottom up in a radical new
experiment in fact rather than
controlling us I think every step
forward in increasing our leader to
communicate has actually driven further
increases in our freedoms and our civil
rights it's allowed new voices to be
heard
it's allowed us to see people that we
never saw before it's a lot of so
literally maybe figuratively look
through the eyes of other people and
have compassion for who they are so on
top of all of the awesome science and
all of the boosts to economic growth and
so on I'm excited about this technology
because I think it might actually make a
world where we understand each other and
empathize with each other a little bit
better that's what I hope for at any
rate so that's what I got thank you very
much it's a delight to be here
[Applause]
that's a good question Jim excellent
okay I couldn't help noticing the old
Microsoft employee was showing us the
iPhone 6 I you know I gave a similar
talk in China actually and I switched to
a huawei Android phone so in Seattle you
never show that right well we'll see
demoness you start out with biotech is
there a way that early adopters that are
the effect will pay off in biotech I
think um and if not how would we make
this happen because what are the major
differences between Moore's Law and how
it's playing out and the potentially
faster acceleration of biotech is that
digital has a really low threshold I
remember a brief period in the 60s when
secretaries organized against word
processors and boy did that go nowhere
and it was fairly because the
intellectuals of the time would normally
critique anything new and you know
criticize it couldn't quite bring
themselves to use the word processors to
criticize digital technology and and so
it swept in both in terms of kind of
easy acceptance it didn't threaten
anything deep like fear about weirdness
with genes and there didn't as you see
it very rapidly costs so much less and
you got so much reward for not getting
on that train that as soon as they could
everybody got on the digital divide more
way as you described perfectly biotech
is code it's digital
like Dawkins said but there's something
fundamentally different about access to
it what's your read on that so what what
Dawkins didn't say is that violent
gyah spaghetti code right it's really
complex
it's very interval then and then on top
of that mostly we apply biology to
humans and there are tolerance for error
is pretty small if you put out some new
code on your servers and it crashes
calling oh that that's often a fix that
you put out a new drug that crashes
that's not good at all so if you want to
look at where I think innovation is
fastest it's where we don't have the
degree of perfection required for a
human health application the people in
the DIY bio field are doing as much in
sort of chemicals and materials and so
on but usually we play out stuff like
that on our pants first as you pointed
out with that wonderful diagram of two
thousand generations of making weird
dogs I would have expected and there's
sort of substitute children for lots of
people anyway and there's no end of
compassion that we put in a net cetera
how come we aren't screaming with their
pets biologically more there are some so
since Molly answered the question that
I'll call her out she's got GMO fish and
her fish tank at home that glow under
bacala blacklight and also made glowing
Gravatt it's still kind of tricky but
the research cost is going down I expect
people will want kittens that stay
kitten like their whole lives best on
sale
you're heard of here first that's gonna
happen so I think we will see more of
this with pets that will be an
interesting translation into humans
isn't that an adorable little baby yeah
working in this way
my parents might have chosen that Matt s
is s you said it was a mistake not to
fund research in genetic manipulation of
human embryos can you expand a little
bit on that yeah so you look at the the
greatest killers of humans and rich
countries heart disease cancer
Alzheimer's not a killer but a huge cost
those if we could snip them in the bud
by getting rid of those genes that the
high risk genes for them in the womb
that would be more humane and
dramatically cheaper than it would be to
go through with dealing with that
medically later on an Alzheimer's
patient can cost hundreds of thousands
of dollars over their lifetime of
treatment the cost of this sort of
procedure should drop to a few thousand
dollars right so if you know that you're
carrying Alzheimer's risk genes that
sort of research is yeah like I said
more humane and lower-cost for society
ultimately so do you think I mean one of
the peculiarities the world knows
there's lots of different parts of the
world taking different attitudes toward
different technologies and as you
pointed out in China they at least
messed around with the human embryo and
embryo form so do you expect that human
applications of biotech are gonna go
faster in some parts of the world they
will Asian cultures just don't have the
same squeamishness about human genetic
manipulation in general why yet people
have speculated that's because of sort
of the religious background Buddhism
versus judeo-christian backgrounds but
who knows really but there was a study
about a decade ago it was my first book
more than human they asked you different
countries would you genetically modify
your kid to have a just an advantage
like more intimate intelligence in the
u.s. it was like 19% yes 81% no in
Thailand I think was the highest was
about 80% yes and China and Japan are
also very high um Kelly yes does the
prospect of the bifurcation human
species as you pointed out that some of
the early warning worries about these
things are also posed they're going to
head toward conformity and you and
well actually had more toward more
variety can the variety go so deep that
we'll see in a few generations humans as
various as to the dogs in that diagram
you know I think it's technically
possible I don't see people making that
many choices that were adequate races I
do think there's there's sci-fi
scenarios to make good sense
humans are not well adapted to space at
all for instance or even a low gravity
planet like Mars we lose bone mass we
can't handle the temperatures radiation
is terrible
genetic tweaks could make it
tremendously easier for someone to
survive and thrive in space or on Mars
so that's a one scenario that makes
sense to me do you know anyone working
on that I don't people writing about it
[Laughter]
Taylor field s and will probably come
back to this in various angles what are
we advancing toward I mean transhuman is
a tremor you use sort of as the element
something in your Nexus series and
something that comes up a lot of we've
never actually heard humans described as
trance apes a pose that's post apes
possible terminology but it's a it's a
it's a excuse to not talk about it
further term in a way said what are we
advancing toward the end don't use the
word transhuman but so there is actual
evolution that are burning incense still
happening in humans but it's it's fairly
weak it's mostly about infectious
disease and so on I think as individuals
people are going to as a species gonna
take control of our evolution but it's
not gonna be central control there's
gonna be family and individual control
and we're gonna make some I think pretty
believable predictable sort of choices
better health less infirmity longer
lives better ability to learn and adapt
to a complex world probably more fun
more joy who wouldn't choose to have a
kid that was more joyous rather than
less
as a society I think we are adapting to
be or evolving to be a society that has
more compassion more empathy that's hard
to believe in the days of Reddit or not
all parts of Reddit event or you know
all sorts of hate storms that happen but
you look around the world and especially
in the US your tolerance people of
different races different genders
different orientations it's
quantitatively just going up and up and
up and I think media has a huge role in
that so one of those features in this
series was Steven Pinker who's better
angels of our nature book sort of
chronicles that expanding circle of
empathy that humans had experienced
novels with various things is the kind
of mind binding melding connecting
broadband looking through the eyes of
others part of that sequence in your
view I think it is I think a lot of
what's happening and I think Pinker is
right on that the world has gotten
better and more civilized I think some
of it is that we evolved as members of a
tribe we evolved most of our existence
we are parts of bands of 20 to 50 or 100
maybe and so anyone who didn't recognize
anyone that look different than you was
other and was probably a threat and so
evolve to just sort of prime on what we
saw or around us as we grew up and treat
anything else with it but now we grow up
in cities that are very diverse and you
open a media environment where we see
people of different colors and genders
and so on and so they no longer look
like other they look like oh that must
be part of my tribe to something that
comes up a lot while we were chatting
beforehand you mentioned it you're about
to get down and burrow into another set
of science fiction books absolutely is
it one book or do you think trilogies is
your mode we'll see yeah right I'll tell
you when I get close to the end but you
mentioned that I asked if it was a
different world this time you said yes
and had to deal with a eyes there's a
thing going around these days
existential threat attached to sir
intelligence AI Nick Bostrom various
people uh what's your relationship to
that and it sounds like great for a
novel it's great for a novel it's too
tempting for a novel it's a great sci-fi
plot so I we've seen it since the
Terminator and so on but I do not see an
existential risk from a eyes as even
remotely plausible for a few reasons
the things that we say eye is almost a
terrible term I wish you didn't have the
term because we apply it to a machine
learning algorithm that can apply a
couple label words to an image and we
apply it to the Terminator and they're
they're not really been even the same
category of things there's very little
incentive for us to create say a
self-driving car that has its own
volition and says no I don't want to go
to that neighborhood so I I just don't
see and that's and that is not going to
happen by accident so I just I don't see
any real work going into or a miniscule
amount of work going into the kind of AI
that would be sentient and have its own
desires and then 99.99% goes into
smarter tools for us you said not in the
next couple years good I don't see it on
the horizon at all actually
okay so horizon is given the century
what the way the scenario plays out is
the super intelligence gets really
really good cell fog mapping yeah
focused on some mission that we've given
it that is not particularly well context
it okay and so in the course of building
whatever it was the right thing building
eliminates humanity it doesn't isn't
even sorry a super intelligent paper
thing yeah
so you see what heading off that kind of
strange
runaway thing I don't see anyone working
on things that are likely to turn out to
them there's a few problems in those
stories first they assumed that a
paperclip factory that's one of the
classic examples a paperclip factory
that just wants make more clips and thus
turns the entire world
raw materials for paperclips right but
why did we give this thing the ability
to go build new factories or to acquire
nuclear weapons or whatever it has to do
in the plot we probably didn't it's not
like software almost never does anything
well by accident I have to debug that
scenario really totally knock that in
stone the other problem is in the
stories there's always just one what
somebody has built one of them that
achieve sentience and there's nothing
else that's like 98% as good or 10,000
other copies of the software running
elsewhere that create some sort of
ecosystem where that balances it out
there's just one in our rogue factory or
oak scientists on an island has built it
didn't tell anyone didn't publish their
papers and then it goes mad and takes
over the world and I'm guilty of
occasionally coming close to this trope
in fiction and I will never do it again
I feel I just I just think it's bonkers
and there's too much of it well here's
another one there are already a eyes
among us they're already post human
intelligences that are smarter than
thousands of us and yet they have not
you know taken over the world
they're called corporations all right
and the Intel has all these processors
and all the people in it's working on
making itself smarter and yet somehow it
has not like turned all of us into chips
or something like that
so without knitting without an
existential threat what's your novel
about AI gonna do to draw us in well I
do think I really think I'll recommend
again the second Machine Age by Van
Alstyne and Roxy in that question of can
software take jobs faster than humans
can keep up is a big one and what is
that how does that affect society and
there's some other nuggets in there that
I will not reveal yeah excellent well I
was around in the 1950s when there were
several books talking about the leisure
crisis that was coming on yeah and what
we're feeling today have no idea
Americans had no idea that you know
educate themselves entertain themselves
they just sit in front of the boob tube
and and gradually train in the muck
didn't happen so John Maynard Keynes one
of the greatest economists of all time
some might say the grid it's gonna a
small time predicted that by now we
would be working about an eight-hour
Work Week right and you might work an
eight-hour Work Week if you wanted a
1920s style quality of life but we don't
there's always new things so far there's
always new things that we want that keep
us motivated to get jobs and do them and
so on so you think that we'll continue
to find ways to do stuff that people
want to pay each other to do with
without machines and all these other
augmentations so I I am NOT as worried
about computers taking away all things
that humans might profitably do I think
they will create more niches that humans
are best at I do think it's legit worry
of when self-driving cars are
commonplace for instance the truck
drivers and taxi drivers who lose their
jobs will those individuals have the
right skill set or we little learn the
right skills to fit into the new job
niches that exist so I think this can be
a a big disruption to society without
being a post work scenario Richard Lee
is mindful meditation seems to be a
larger theme throughout the nexus
trilogy can you speak to some of the
impacts and the interactions of
neurotoxins design clear in relation to
I mean do you meditate I'm sort of a
laughs meditator last one yes well you
write very vividly about it and make it
very attractive thank you so I recall it
I mean I was a the pasta non meditator I
recommend it highly and there's a lot of
sort of shown benefits of it and I'm
also fascinated that the the Buddhist
leaders and the Dali Lama PQR have
really engaged with neuroscience so I
know two neuroscientists that have three
now that have spent time with the Dalai
Lama they've put Buddhist meditators in
brain scanners and so I find that in
addition to finding it very fulfilling
myself I just find that connection of
science and meditation really
fascinating mullahs and popes have not
gone in for that so much no different
different approaches I wonder what
happened certain they will um the
meditation angle in the Nexus series is
pretty much your handle what an ascent
what a kind of an expanded mindfulness
where it is multi mindfulness shared
mindfulness say more about how that
emerges something I've seen in no other
science fiction so in in Nexus we
discover that one group of people that
have been using this technology are
Buddhist monks that have been taking it
and meditating and syncing up with each
other as they do if you go to meditation
retreat and you're in a room full of
people and meditating you you can hear
what else breathing and you sort of
naturally fall into sync if you're a
yoga class you should asana at the end
you're kind of all in your own heads but
in this together philosophically one of
the sort of presumptions of Buddhism is
that the separateness of uii is an
illusion right and that one of the
points enlightenment
as the realization that everything is
just net is an artificial boundary so I
wanted to play with what if we actually
did have a connective in our brains how
would that affect and amplify this idea
of mindfulness and meditating and
inspecting your own mind I know it's
great fun I think you've nailed part of
the future of whole this comes together
Thank You nose thank you sir
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you